please welcome my friend chelsea clinton
[Applause]
oh gosh i just my children are large
drew and you have two boys i do and my
two and a half year old's a giant
okay so the last time you came here was
like the morning after the insurrection
it was the morning after the
insurrection and here we are
uh in the middle of a new war
and
how do we
persevere
how do we go about our days when such
difficult things are happening
oh gosh drew well there
there is a lot um happening i mean here
in our city of new york across our
country and certainly around the world
we see the ongoing humanitarian crisis
in ukraine although we know that
ukraine isn't the only country in the
world that is under kind of war and
violence and kind of
threat from outside or inside
and i think either we can drown in the
despair
or we can decide to try to do something
about it
and i think there is a lot that we can
do i mean for those of us with resources
we can donate to the international
rescue committee and so many of the
amazing organizations who are on the
front lines trying to give people food
and medical support and hope we can put
continued pressure
kind of
especially for those of us who live in
democracies to have a unified effort to
stand up
to putin and all of his brutality
um because i think ultimately drew
optimism is a moral choice
and i think it is the more moral choice
to choose to be optimistic to choose to
believe that our efforts and our
energies can make a difference
because otherwise we just all like put
our covers over our heads and i don't
think that's going to make us feel very
good right i think that's then just
seeding to hopelessness i would much
rather try to
act hopeful and try to create more hope
in the world so that that happiness you
talk about is hard won because we know
we have all tried to do our part
and you just did it
you just did it
i always love
that you and i also i
cannot hold a candle to your experience
growing up
in front of everybody i i just i love
asking you life advice because
you are very full of grace and i don't
how do you do it how how do you remain
this full of grace while the world is
difficult while people are divided or
different what's your one foot in front
of the other
well i think
being myself
somewhat stubbornly
um i'm terrible at being other people
but i just am not an actress i don't
have those genes like you do and i can't
do it in real life i can't fake anything
i can't fake anything and and
yet then i do know i have to
um
take care of myself so that i can
hopefully take care of others the others
in kind of the smaller world of my
family and the others in the in the
bigger sense of the work that i feel
called to do whether as a as an author
or an advocate so i spend a lot of time
with my kids because they just bring me
so much joy
and i spend a lot of time running
because i find running is like my
meditative space
and i'm also i'm quite religious and i
was able to finally go back in person to
church a few weeks ago which meant a
huge amount
to me to be able to be kind of in the
sanctuary was a very different
experience than live stream although
like god bless my minister for
just
never giving up on those of us on the
other side of the screen who she
couldn't see or kind of be with in
in kind of physical community and so all
of that really
matters to me and is then how i try to
help remind myself that i do matter so
then i can try to do more work that i
hope creates more more possibility for
more people in more places and you do
church
running
stubbornly being yourself all three of
those things seem doable attainable
admirable when you move your body you do
shift your chemistry
[Music]
you